you've seen it countless times in the
last year it's really accelerated in the
last year since george floyd died
but affluent professional white people
reaching a kind of religious ecstasy
talking about how much they despise
themselves because of their own skin
color
mainstream protestantism died in this
country and
this variety of self-loathing appears to
have taken
its place here's the latest example
yesterday i realized that
i'm white and that i have all the
advantages
of being part of that group i was
reading white fragility
i'm like oh okay i think
i'm taking that next step in my journey
to understanding what's happening
what equity is about what racial equity
is about
what anti-racism is about and what
racism
i realized that i'm white as part of a
white
supremacy culture
the next step of my journey all of this
by the way at its root is just pure
narcissism
and that's why it only appeals to a
certain kind of professional
class unhappy person many of them
females be totally honest about it but
not exclusively anyway it's terrible
it's racist by definition
you shouldn't hate people or yourself
because of how you were born or your
skin color that's the opposite
of what this country stood for it's the
opposite what martin luther king
preached
and it makes it impossible to live as a
country
if this crap continues but it is
continuing in fact it's accelerating
the state of washington just made
anti-weight training mandatory for all
staff
in all public schools jason rantz has
been following this story as a radio
show host out in seattle joins us
tonight hey jason good to see you
good to see you mandatory huh yeah it's
mandatory and just to go over some of
the training only white people can be
racist slavery was never actually
abolished
low-income white people actually are
benefiting from their white privilege
now that's just from highline public
schools this is a district a little bit
south of seattle
now according to the law all of these
schools actually have to start teaching
the so-called anti-racist
equity training which is actually in
favor of racism
and does not lead to equitable outcomes
quite the opposite
but there are a lot of school districts
all across the state that are already
doing this and this is one district for
example
that's been doing this for years they've
got a race symposium which is where that
video came from
so one teacher who was pretty upset
about the
documents that were put in front of this
teacher and some of the
videos and the training actually leaked
a lot of this to me and i just pulled
some of the cuts including race as a
social construct created to advance
white supremacy and that if you get
defensive when you're called a racist
well of course that's also white
supremacy culture in action
they're being told that may i interrupt
you
right there wait i mean i don't think
any of us want to live in a country
where people are racially self-conscious
where you think about your race all the
time that you don't want to live in that
place it's rwanda it's bad
has it occurred to any of these geniuses
that they are going to make your average
white person
racially self-aware some of them really
radical in a bad way
if they keep up with this crap if they
keep attacking people on the basis of
qualities those people can't control
like they're creating radicalism do they
know that
they i don't think they realize that
they're doing that because they're
talking to a very specific
group of people that they're trying to
become subservient
to an ideological cause and they think
they're justified
in the shaming the race-based shaming
that they're doing
to these people and eventually doing to
these kids that's really what this is
about they're not really focused on the
adults they're not talking to the adults
they're talking to the kids
this training right now is going to be
to the staff members but the
end goal is to propagandize indoctrinate
children
that's the end goal and when you get all
of our nation's kids
believing this garbage this trash this
toxic
thinking well then when they're in
charge it doesn't matter that
older folks who are dying out actually
hold that position that's how they think
they're trying to create a revolution
one
critical race theory training session at
a time it really
is nefarious in its intent and i don't
think they realize
or really care about the danger that
it's creating
in this environment and thankfully
there are teachers who are leaking a lot
of this stuff out
who are complaining and who aren't going
to put this in front of kids but it's
the parents
that really need to step up and protect
them from this
yes stop being passive put down the bomb
do something about this this will wreck
the country for real
this is really scary i appreciate your
reporting on it
jason rantz thank you thanks tucker
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else